zwei besseres als diamant beiden schutz
auf studien gemacht
[Musik]
das wollen wir wieder tolle hallo wir
sind also ich hatte einfach gerade so
was von die todesangst dass irgendwelche
lover hingesetzt hat aber da wir direkt
erstmal machen wollen ist umstritten
weil wir sind sie sind ich dachte schon
heute schon wieder wm beigetreten aber
das war nach der einnahme du ja ja ja
dann kommt dann komm komm komm doch
gleich mit ich hab mir schon geöffnet
weil folgen das wäre also musste erst
mal deine sachen hier voll gepackt mit
den sachen austria ja mach jetzt mal so
unsere sache müssen jetzt nicht mit
seiner platin oder sonst wem ich so viel
mit wie geht und alles was ich brauche
weil der plan der plan der plan ist
krass übrigens diese eisenbahnen die wir
gefunden haben weil ich nicht mitnehmen
du noch die suppen mit wie wir von
suppen habe ich fast alle dabei die wir
von early boy mitgenommen haben wir sind
ein bisschen denn hektik weil wir ja
tatsächlich mitbekommen haben dass ein
paar durch ich möchte jetzt hier keine
namen nennen oder irgendwie sowas dass
das 1 1 ein paar mitglieder diesen
können können wir los wie kilos oder ich
nehme das schild kann ich nicht das kann
das ist das heck mitglieder in das
skript abbas auf das direkt am eingang
kurz mal weg schnitt 4,8
dann halte ich war ja also wir haben
mitbekommen dass ein paar mitglieder in
diesem projekt das wir gerade auch
völlig völlig überzogen wird als opfer
einer polit profis sind ja eigentlich
und es ist unglaublich ist das ja auch
so heißt ich sitz hier wirklich einfach
nur im unterhemd also es ist so heiß so
heißt du bist so heißt ja so wie er
mitbekommen dass das einparken heute
mache ich mal hier kurz mal haben wir
mitbekommen dass nochmal hier einfach
irgendwohin ja ein bisschen was ein
bisschen weiter hinten zu diesem zu
diesem berg da gehen wir mitbekommen
dass eben ein paar nette menschen
angefangen haben sich wirklich
positionen der mitglieder
herauszuschreiben und dadurch die
gegenwart erzählen und schulden das war
keine absicht
und deswegen haben uns gedacht wir
ziehen wirklich gleich zur sicherheit
noch mal um was wir dann
dieser folge noch machen werden ich habe
mich tatsächlich wieder immer
geschrieben höhe conti und ghettos für
die minecraft profis spielen das spiel
seit 8000 jahren und habe keine ahnung
wie dumm wird geht und ich hab mich ein
bisschen informiert und rausgefunden ich
nehme ich bleib bei diesem klischee als
dabei genau und herausgefunden wie wir
das haben schon andere dem projekt
gemacht diverse tote leute vielleicht
doch daraus gleich gut ist wenn wir das
machen aber ich rausgefunden so um den
satz jetzt endlich zu beenden ich habe
acht mal angefangen voll auf dem damm
gerade ins ziel
ich hab' ich habe welches ja aber ich
kann der kann ja dann auch weismachen
alles alles kein ding alles easy so und
jedenfalls kann ich jetzt zum fünften
mal unsere sachen das ist und wer die
tödlichen inspiriert mich jetzt mal
außer williams pilot ist unterbricht
sich andauernd ich bin nun brauche auch
kohle abwägen experience naja ok so
jedenfalls kann ich unsere schwerter und
auch unsere rüstung auf stufe 2
verzaubern also die diamant schwerer auf
schärfe zwei vielleicht sogar drei mal
gucken wir weiter kommen und
kostengünstiger als wenn wir uns massiv
bücherregale machen nämlich mit einem
amboss und deswegen wird sich auch das
eisen dass wir von early boy geklaut
haben hier einfach wunderschön
dafür braucht man viel ja wir wollen wir
wollen hier in lucka kombibau einfach
reinmachen
diese das ist schön dass noch keiner auf
den server getöntes ja das heißt dass
wir uns auch gedacht haben ist wir
machen uns einen vorraum das heißt nicht
dass irgendwer denkt ihr
da ist ein zwei leute drin so einfach
hier ist mal so einen vorraum und dann
machen wir das war so eine dumme idee
heute morgen bei dem bei ich reagiere
sehr schlecht auf wetterwechsel habe ich
dem konfiguration erzählt habe ich ein
bisschen was vor geholt von wegen
migräne und ich hab meine tage unsere
zeit später ja genau steht auch schon
bei twitter
und der punkt ist ich war dann heute
morgen doch noch relativ schnell
trainieren und ich war schon lange nicht
mehr
und jetzt jetzt zittert die ganzen
unterleib so als hätte mich jemand
richtig hart vergewaltigt also nicht
wundern wenn ich jetzt haben wir den
salat fisch mitgenommen ich habe den
gott sei dank ich hatte ich hatte schon
angst so dass man hier gleich ich habe
fackeln ja ich dir mal aus ja klar
und manchmal den die eine basis davon an
den das kann ich auch ihnen zu machen so
dass wir da
ja sie bedenken dass jemand basis war
weiß dass ein bisschen hier war hier
waren an der basis vor jahren stellte
weist ein bisschen sonne aber feine
technik legen und sagen was du kannst du
mir gleich mal die kräftig tablet
stellen dann kann ich schon mal nebenbei
anfangen hier die die sachen klar zu
machen für die verzauberung soja das
kreuz das brauche ich das jetzt bräuchte
gothic tale so uns war ein bisschen
größer und ich will jetzt nach unten
gehen die haben mir drei eisen blöcke
machen
ihr seht ich bin wirklich ich bin laut
ich bin bin so kaske skilled nicht
normal ich habe bloß keine ordnung beim
inventar urlaub gehabt irgendwas
weggeworfen habe es auch kommen aber
hier wird ein bisschen rein so 13 57 und
der backups getrieben mit der dicken
fetten markt weil er große brüste mag
genau das ist auch unser motto in diesem
projekt einfach ganz mir ein paar fakten
geben wenn jetzt nach unten gehen sie so
so so so jedoch verzauberung is king of
the ring ding ding dong
ich habe vorher nie mit einem amboss
gearbeitet ich habe das nur für dieses
projekt gelernt wie man wie man mit
diesem ganzen scheiß um gebe ich konnte
doch nichts ich betone noch mal wirklich
nicht so ich dachte schon was war da
denn aber ich finde dass niemand einfach
vielleicht habe ich auch einfach solche
respekt vor uns weil wir sind einfach
somit die best ausgerüsteten weil wenn
ihr diese folge sehen sie jetzt ihr
wahrscheinlich auch schon das steht wie
tot ist hat das ist es nicht schon
wissen
und sonst die anderen teams die sonst
alleine besser ausgerüstet sind sind
eigentlich alle so einzel team sondern
tritt ist richtig gut ausgerüstete hat
ja auch den unter bergmann weggeklappt
ist ja inzwischen auch schon bekannt und
auch ziemlich gut also erst mal wichtig
dann dich du alte albaner was geht bei
die aber petri das immer noch scheiße
warum nicht über diskutieren also als
person ist das einfach ein mega
abgefragt
glauben die jetzt werde ich ja ja ich
weiß das glaube ich nicht ernst nehmen
leute so ich mache jetzt mal hier in der
höhle gefangen war noch nicht drin war
so ich habe jetzt mal drei bücher hier
am start das ist ganz cool war ich meine
nein mein unterleib ich weiß wo ich habe
mich glaube ich aber echt meine tage und
jetzt kann man nicht bücher kann man auf
level 1 verzaubern und manchmal kommt
jetzt ist hier stärker eins raus
gekommen das ist nicht so cool
wir brauchen schärfe mit dem buch
stärker ich bekomme nur stärke das nicht
gut da sieht es wieder nach da heißt es
ist noch nicht so gut wasser affinität
super also das hat bisher nicht so gut
nicht so gut klappt soll ich machen
wollen aber ich glaube man kann doch
auch stärker auf dem schwert packen oder
aber die auf level 2 ist kaputt die
aufnahme zwei verzaubert sind und welche
wir haben jetzt also das kann entweder
schiefgehen oder nicht so jetzt habe ich
drei bücher verzaubert und hab da nur
knapp raus bekommen also stärke und
wasser affinität bringt mir nicht
sonderlich viel deswegen muss ich noch
mal bücher machen aber ich darf nicht
alle unserer zuckerrohr benutzen ich
lass mal ich das mal vier übrig du ich
würde sogar noch mehr übrig lassen falls
wir das dann irgendwie noch schon schon
passiert schon passiert ist geil
ja ich bin gut war da jetzt war da mal
hier ab das problem ist wir kriegen hier
ich mir keinen kein keine schärfe raus
deswegen alter wieso kriege ich nur
stärke weißt du bei den anderen
innerhalb von drei sekunden kriegen die
masse schärfe mit stärke kann ich nichts
anfangen kann ich keine anfragen geht es
übrigens auch alles super ausgeleuchtet
damit ihr bei mir richtig viel sollte
man ich muss mich muss ich mal dass ein
bisschen mehr mehr relaxen also was wir
jetzt machen könnten so das problem ist
jetzt dass man kurz gucken dann beschuss
schutz sicher 1
also was wir was wir machen können ist
die ich mal meine rüstung mache ich mal
hoch das kann ich machen indem ich hier
in dem ich die sachen kombiniere ich
mache das jetzt bestimmt mal wieder so
wie es nicht am effektivsten ist oder
soja aber ihr wisst ja hier sind wir
sind groß wir sind post also auch schon
immer aber ich probieren wir mal ein
bisschen was zu bitteren ende
entschuldigung ich habe ist so eine
geile hürde gefallen aber ziemlich
einfach keinen fall mehr
aber ich hab ja heute und kann mir
fackeln machen und ich habe auch gleich
eine spitzhacke männer und eine
spitzhacke dann schärfe draufpacken
liga so und wenn wir jetzt nämlich hier
wir brauchen so etwas wie glück bei
diamanten alter das war so geil so war
da jetzt mal sondern das ist eine höhere
vertrag und das hat schon mal
funktioniert ich habe meinen helm auf
stufe 2
das hat schon mal funktioniert von
irgendwo irgendwie muss nachher
hochkommen und mit einer rüstung geben
damit dann kann ich dir auch petra
getötet und auf schutz zwei machen und
meine reisen beim schutz kann ich mir
auch da habe ich ja schon die am
handball in schutz
das bringt ja dann natürlich auch nicht
mehr obwohl wahrscheinlich eine
eisenbahn schutz auf stufe 2 besser ist
als diamant waren schutz auf stufe seien
kein schaden gemacht warum ein junger es
ist jetzt an das machst mich ich habe
auch gesagt ein bisschen angst erhöht
obwohl ich weiß dass die mir alle
irgendwie nichts können so weißt du wie
ich das jetzt mach ich das ist dass es
sicher geht ich probiere das jetzt mal
kurz die leute das ist jetzt bei mir ist
das mega langweiliges hin und her die
leute ist so stehen die verstehen wie
ich bin auch noch erhöhe und kämpfe
gegen zehn millionen option ist das mega
spannend also bei mir ist auch nichts
besseres
die ist nicht verstehen verstehen es
nicht aber ich meine niemand versteht
auch lukas leben das ist
mysterium damit beschäftigt sich jeder
seite raus ich muss mal raus und ich
besonders ein bisschen holz es war es
ist vor dunkel
ich habe auch gerade holz geholt aber
ich bin ja mit der höhle ich weiß gar
nicht ist es besser wenn ich stripperin
oder besser wenn ich einfach in der
höhle ganz nach unten gehe ob ich hatte
ja man also es tut man das eigentlich
meistens effektiver habe ich so das
gefühl egal ich glaube dass man
irgendwie spannend hier jetzt ist ja
noch was luca hier mal wieder spannende
folgen machen das jetzt mal ohne spaß
das ist so geil das will ich einfach
eine höhle gefunden habt die norton
niemand erkundet hat ich finde oder so
müssen wir sind in folge nummer
irgendwas und ich muss raus und holz von
hand klopfen organisiert wir haben
irgendwann auf sex gehabt aber das war
mir irgendwie zu blöd dass zu suchen und
ich kann ja auch mal kurz hier so ein
bisschen raus hüpfen ja das muss ja auch
mal erlaubt sein finde ich hier kommt
wasser von oben rein mensch so wir
müssen auch wieder ich glaube du hast
das kleinste müssen dass nachher hier
wieder zu machen ja also richtig zu
machen so dass es wieder ordentlich
aussieht was soll ich denn jetzt gerade
machen ich wollte wollte wollte weil er
wollte das ist so dieses verzaubern
wenn man das mal drauf hat ist cool aber
wenn man das nicht drauf hat unsere
minecraft nutzt sind wie wir dann so
minecraft nook sind wie sie wenig mit
einer migräne einfach vergraben sie
einfach weg
ich finde ich mal computer wie geht in
ordnung im gegensatz zu deinen kommt ist
einfach immer beschissen ja du junge ich
bin niemand war da ich habe ihn ja
niemand
das wird gemacht und mit etwas glück ich
hoffe das funktioniert jetzt weh wenn
ich wie du dir denn die art ja aber doch
guck mal du kannst du kannst dir
schwerer machen und dann kannst du die
kombinieren dann hast du ein diamant mit
stärke 1 und ein dritter verein vergibt
das 1 1 mit schärfe zwei dienstag aber
dafür war ich ein bisschen mehr
erfahrung deswegen sie wieder irgend was
abgucken gehen nach sodass man
sicherstellt machen oder man kann es mit
büchern machen aber ich habe das mit den
büchern probiert und bei den büchern ist
es halt unwahrscheinlicher da kannst du
alle möglichen verzauberungen
rausbekommen ja das heißt eben von für
die für die normalen items also für für
für für hier du weißt schon was für
spitzhacken und sowas oder vermisst und
das kannst du nicht auf die später
machen das heißt es ist unwahrscheinlich
dass du halt schärfe
schärfe 1 bekommst und das habe ich bei
den drei büchern die ich verzaubert hat
sich bekommt deswegen muss ich würde dir
schwert machen ist gewiss gar nicht mehr
zahlen würde hat so hat so funktioniert
und ich klatsch tratsch aus ein paar
spinnen ab einfach mal so als just for
fun bekommst eine wiese very funny sexy
bei einem looping bänderriss party like
hell
ich habe kilos ich habe geradezu angst
ist ja einfach sterben werde
warum ich habe schärfe zwei die
schwerter ja ich habe einen schock ich
habe ich finde den weg wieder zurück das
okay das ist okay du kannst dann auch
gleich hoch kommen dann kann ich dir
nicht einfach fünf teilen kannst du mich
vielleicht mal besuchen kommen ja auch
noch liefern alles hochkommt weil ich
gucke jetzt kurz vielleicht ja ich weiß
aber nicht wo es hochgeht du sonst
wieder hochkommen ok ich brauche erstmal
wieder einig ich komm ich komme gleich
warum habe ich brauche erstmal wieder
ein level damit ich das kann nämlich
keine level mehr profi
soweit ich kann mir das hier alles rein
so also meinst es auch schutz zwei das
andere ist auf schusssicher 1 so ein
dreck also wirklich zeigt dass man halt
auch mal wieder zu hause bitte gib mir
direkt was zu essen
jaja da kommt dann kommt hoch werden
dass sich zeugen der kiste auch richtig
stark dass jetzt einfach mit komplett
abgedeckt haben da kann man auch mal was
beraten
vielleicht mal was bringt der sinn einer
doppelten basis ist dass wir das einfach
ich habe ich habe ich habe ja ich habe
ja gesagt das müssen wir jetzt gib mir
mal kurz jetzt gehst du mal schnee mal
normal war dann immer mal mit mal ohne
mal dass das schwert hier so jan
erstmals wird es wohl geahnt jetzt gießt
eine verzauberung zwischen verzaubert
auf 1 ja also auf level 1 dieses schwert
einfach auf level 1 ja das ist euer wird
das und verzauberte auf level 1 ist muss
er 1 dran stehen ja ok chef 1 so jetzt
gehst du auf den amboss und dann legst
du deine beiden diamant schwer da rein
und dann ergibt das ein schärfe zwei die
hamas auch umbenennen wie umbenennen er
ist kostenlos ich habe aber nur 21
auch ein 20 19 wie du brauchst 21 dafür
ja es gibt das ganze das kann nicht sein
dass sein da stand 21 ich glaube eben da
kannst du noch mal um transportieren
aber jedenfalls so du hast verstand wie
funktioniert oder auf jeden fall ich
gehe jetzt mal eben hier nochmal
bisschen
jetzt bin ich in der w-20 weil er
einfach erfahrung um lag ich über das
bin ich bin profi
ja ich nehme jetzt einfach hier die
ganze so jetzt war dann halt nicht und
dann kannst du eben auch hier drinnen
liegt noch ein eisen helm oder eine
eisen hose auch auf schutz ein sondern
kannst du das gleiche da machen du hast
ja verstanden wie das prinzip ist gerade
aufenthalt dann kannst du dir das kannst
du da auch die verzauberung verdoppelt
nicht einfach mal ja also luca jetzt
muss mal wirklich du weißt du hast du
den sonderschulen abschluss hat ist
jetzt nicht so naiv ja nichtmal
abschluss zur zeit die du weißt du hast
kein abschluss und schwinge ich dass
mich jetzt von dem skelett okay ich
glaube dass das müssen wir einfach
abknallen kann aber ein bisschen
entspannen
das macht er so viel schaden tut wird
der match aber das macht die rüstung
kaputt deswegen dass ich das jetzt
machen wir wieder so damit hier nicht
mit juristen direkt flöten geht nicht
mehr so hart erarbeitet hat ich glaube
ich auch noch mal runter und gucken
bisschen nach gras kannst das allgemein
besser also ich bin ja wieder 21 machen
jetzt mal so ein tolles ding ist hier
machst du da mal ein bisschen rum ist
glaube ich eine ganz gute idee ja das
ist gut auf jeden fall und dann erst es
läuft es läuft auch sauber ohne ende
also mein ganzes werk uns doch und du
kannst dich auch mal um das zuckerrohr
bitte kümmern dass du das mal anbaus und
vielleicht noch mehr so ist das war ganz
gut wo haben wir denn überhaupt da ist
doch steigen dann machen wir das auch
das jetzt erstmal alles hierzu also
scheint wächst auf seinen schneller aber
ehrlich gesagt glaube ich das nicht
möglich doch dürfe sonst ihren ich habe
ja sogar extra sandmann mitgenommen
dürfte ich mir aus den vier
verbleibenden diamanten aus diamant
schule machen oder wollen wir erst mal
gesprochen
ich würde sagen wir behalten die erst
mal ist das erstmal sparen weil wir
können eigentlich in den yahoo somalias
sparen weil wir können uns dann noch mal
zwei diamant schwer damit machen und
unsere sparte auf scharfe drei bringen
weil das mit den büchern
guck mal ich habe mir diese bücher
gemacht habe ich verzaubert und da ist
bei keinem einfach mal schärfe
rauskommen das war vier mal völlig
umsonst also das ist so ein bisschen
mehr glücksspiel und bei den schwertern
ist es viel wahrscheinlicher schärfe zu
bekommen deswegen dass das mit den mit
den schwertern machen und dann haben wir
die vier ist nämlich schon mal sicher
geht ja sondern es können dann können
wir sobald wir die level oben haben
können wir nämlich dann schärfte drei
machen und mit schärfe drei sind wir
ganz schön die bauwirtschaft ich habe
jetzt auch diese sie müssen einfach nur
an laverty hat mit deiner scheiße ich
habe den eisen helm auch auf schutz zwei
verzaubert mit den beiden anderen
eingepackt mit schutz kann ich jetzt
noch nicht weil das kostet wieder
irgendwie ein paar erfahrungen
das heißt ich gehe jetzt was ist ein
ausgang das nicht gut ja ich jetzt erst
jetzt direkt indirekt einen direkten
ausgang das ist nicht cool du du weißt
dass ich war das kleine ein reh fand ich
ganz einfach auch mal weiter strippen
ihren gast dass die höhle die gemeint
ist oder wie wir ja die war ich aber
schon komplett durch dazu dieser ist
halt dass wir am besten vielleicht ich
dachte schon explodiert im wasser war
einfach nur wenig abgebaut habe achim
heckel sind das gehen ach da da da bist
du da bist du ja wir können auch beide
strip mal hingehen genau dann mach mal
du dich mal wiederholen dass das
eigentlich sind sie machen anderen gang
das ist wenn ich jetzt hier war da bist
du irgendwann mal einen abschluss
was anders machen das foto an finanzen
das was du ich bin jetzt steht mining
profi weiß bei mir sind die leute auch
gewohnt ist zu sehen in den folgen
deswegen wenn das jetzt wenn du das auch
noch anfängt und schauen uns jemanden
dazu jetzt habe ich direkt nichts zu
holen
wir machen das jetzt sogar einfach zu
damit dass hier ein bisschen seriös
aussieht naja du du siehst du siehst
seriös aus verständlich ist so
unglaublich attraktiv begriff sich
dadurch 16 minuten 40 das wird unser
erster strike scheiße dies wird unser
erster streik legal ist eine von dreien
naja gut bei die feuerwehr ein bisschen
überzogen egal muss auch mal an seinen
alltag darf ich jetzt aber auch noch ein
gedicht aufsagen oder kannst du machen
du weißt schön luca ist toll bei bahro
wenn ich das sterben nicht ganz so lasst
euch gefallen hat auf jeden fall
tschüss